current status of our destiny beta
stream sean is level four having a dance
party oh yeah i'm watching the opening
cut scene mary was into the opening part
of the mission but then her controller
crapped out
so we're having some interference issues
there this is my favorite part of
destiny so far just running into a
random player out in the wild and then
you just dance and it's like oh he wants
to lay with you
i'll lay with this dude
next to a decapitated fallen
don't mind if i do
you guys had a nice little session there
uh making friends and there he goes
goodbye
give me a second
well
he's dancing with you in his
ship we're also still giving away
destiny beta keys way to win one of
those is to get into the game spot
comments on our live stream here leave a
comment about why you want a beta key
and then you'll be entered to win a code
that when entered on bungie.net will
give you the option to choose xbox 360
xbox one ps3 or ps4 that will all
explain itself once you put in the code
but one note xbox 360 and xbox one beta
does not start for another week that's
true
really it's part of the whole timed
exclusive thing uh sony has been putting
a lot of
has this marketing campaign going with
uh destiny obviously that you know you
get exclusive access to the beta a week
early you've they've got a that bundle
coming out with the white ps4 um
also once you put in your code that is
what you get uh once you put in your
platform so
if you wanna play with your friends you
might wanna make sure you put the code
in that you can play with them on and
the codes yield
three codes ours i believe yeah
yeah a single
destiny beta code that you redeem on
bungie.net yields three
playstation network three codes for the
platform of your choice yeah
go on
don't be alarmed at things crashing off
screen you just we just had a
piece of video equipment fall down
i'm sure it was nothing let's check it
out they're both linked to something in
skywatch you gotta infiltrate the
skywatch current status of this mission
breach the old array complex to locate
the source of the fallen operation
that's what i'm doing right now go sean
go
like i crossed the streams
sean once you get into your next uh
combat situation yes you need to show us
that warlock power man
oh yeah i do
just show us your warlock
force blast whatever
all right force blast coming right up
yeah that's what it's called
technical terms
you might surpass me catching up i know
so many issues
what i'm gonna get on my sparrow
guys i can't wait until we can group up
and be best friends
i can't wait to dance if y'all can i
sparrow joust i can't wait to take you
guys on level six
strikes while you're level two oh man
some people are questioning are asking
about pc it's not on pc currently bungie
has not confirmed that it'll be on pc
however they have strongly hinted that
they will
the beta or the game the game the game
nope
not yet it has not been confirmed
will there be sony exclusive content
i think so probably perhaps all right so
if you guys are wondering what the kind
of like effect on my screen is right now
i assume we're on my screen uh i i've
entered what's called a darkness zone
and essentially what that means is that
normally when you die you'll wait a
little bit and then you respawn in that
same place but here if you die you have
to go back to the beginning of that
darkness zone so it's basically just
kind of a hey shit's about to get real
buckle up kind of a warning
the plow kablelo all right do you want
to see my uh my ability i want to see
your feel like it's not quite serious
enough yet yeah come on you need to get
real real just smash it on one dude
oh that dude died before i could smash
those ducks did go down quick yeah
those are like little whoa
ability
oh man oh you just went to punch mode
i think that's just that's what i do
when i get scared i go into punch mode
did this guy die standing up
i did
send that to bungie
people are dying standing up
all right
that was my super right there that was
my nova blast
which is kind of a
it's essentially it's a it's a
it's like a fireball it's a hadoop it's
a hadouken it's a hookah
it's a space hadouken is what the nova
blast is more or less
but there is some splash damage to it so
you don't
necessarily have to get a direct hit
horseblast
did you say horse blast yes
that is a mean horse blast
oh we got invisibles coming this way
what up jerks oh stealth vinnies
you're gonna die oh no don't die
watch out
i think you're relying on your horse
blast a little too much it's a it's not
a horse blast come on guys
that's what i heard it was
i heard horse blast it's not a horse
blast
don't call it a horse blast i'll call it
a comeback
eat it doug going picklebot
oh [ __ ] don't die oh [ __ ] i died
all right i definitely relied on my
horse blast a little bit too much
sean
you can't
there we go figure out the horse blast
situation
all right i'm now playing so i'm going
to be saying weird stuff occasionally
deal with it
oh
so you're
infiltrating a witch kind of thing
r1 punch
sorry i i punch now you're asking me
like very fragmented questions i know
sean i'm just starting to play destiny
and i'm now like really just kind of
confused about life
i think i'm back
mary are you back i think i am all right
we are going to meet up at the tower
place all right you guys should buddy up
we're going to beat up
i have to redo um a lot of stuff here
unfortunately you'll you'll be good
you'll be fine oh mary i'm not worried
about you mary
thanks guys
it
oh take that
fallen captain you got four arms but no
head
how do you like that four arms but no
head because i shot his hands i shot his
head off as well
the situation
that he has that's how he that's how he
became
you got four arms but no head is my
favorite country you got four arms
you are so good at that
oh what
the worst time to reload
you know what i think i got a little too
aggressive in this area before i'm gonna
let these guys come to me there's no
reason for me to charge in their guns
they're going to come at you man just
let them come let them come at me yeah
let them do the hard work dogs can come
on down yeah doug's
you guys can teach me how to dougie
oh eat it oh my god
eat it eat it so hard eat it so hard eat
it the worst oh boy
that was oh i love
i love the effect of their body kind of
like floating into the ether after you
nail them with a
nova bomb
so good so satisfying
you know what's satisfying on my end
snickers that my my melee attack is just
a straight up punch oh what oh yes
it looks like a real solid punch it's
just some
thick right hook i'd like to see it can
i see it again big hank just coming with
a
club
haymaker
all right yeah you'll be able to see it
mine is a knife to the jowls
the jowls to the jowls
what if they don't have jowls what if
you're not attacking wilford brimley
yeah what if you're not attacking a 90
year old man it's in the jowls
get him in the gym talk about jowls in
here
we be talking about jaws we talking
about
jowls so sean what your level what
are you facing level four enemies mostly
or are you it seems like mostly
occasionally i've run into
higher level enemies
but that is definitely the bulk of the
enemies the plurality of enemies
i love before
so you're saying the bulky enemies are
level four yeah bulky enemies are the
fat ones
how are you doing on your little baby
mission chris i'm doing fine i'm
shooting a lot of ones
so if you guys are just tuning in
uh i got started playing first
because i uh you know download i started
my download first these guys drag their
feet a little bit
we started downloading i'm sure we
wanted to live stream the destiny beta
on our live stream destiny beta was
given based on cool points sean won oh
yeah yeah
mary came in second i languished far
behind in third but now i'm catching up
and i'm actually further than mary
because of some technical issues but
soon mary and i will meet up and
join a fire team together it'll be just
me and my best friend
and then i'll come join your guys fire
team when i'm done with my grown-ups
you'll be such a higher level than us
well
you know it's fitting because i'm also
at a higher skill level yeah
i mean we're gonna have to see what it's
like when you play with people of
multiple
different of multiple uh what do you
call them levels levels is the word i'm
searching for yeah that's the one all
right
blast eat it so hard oh
i love my suit
dude the punch is so funny
you just clock them
just [ __ ] ring their bell
pow
you just clock them once
none of this stabbing or like space
wizard powers just good old-fashioned
earth muscles
you just clock them like that kablammy
that's
you're really enjoying yourself oh my
god it feels so fun
oh i gotta level up my habili daddys
all right
i'm doing pretty good over here guys i
just cleared out this whoa no no didn't
what nope
nope nope
to me there's a spoke too soon value
when a game gives you that really
really good feeling oh absolutely when
you shoot someone
just that
feeling of impact dab them in the jowls
i think it's
really valuable yeah
hit them with a jowl shot
right in the jaws
what are these
servitor things my melees are you
attacking something new so this was kind
of one of those little um the ghost is
hacking the computer you need to defend
the area for a minute missions
um although the minute is actually more
like 10 minutes uh-huh uh so it's just
like increasingly powerful enemy waves
coming in at you a hot minute
so
are the servant tron things all right
i've
they're shooting like
weird
they're like weird eyeball
nasty bits that thing's cool this thing
is dope
you die i think it's dope kill it i got
my nova blast going on
oh you want a piece of that
you gotta press triangle to go oh do it
i'm excited you get your granata those
ones are tough
all right i'm gonna survey the ground
and make sure that these guys didn't
drop anything of use oh they dropped
you got some vector oath boots oh yeah
are you able to use uh lace-up boots now
are you out of belt please chris please
come on
those those boots are old news he's
ragging i know how to use those boots
now shawn is dragging on your boots it's
been a while
since you knew how to do that you know i
actually should make sure that i don't
have any new items
oh okay so i now have the ability to
upgrade
oh my helmet so that's what we were
talking about earlier we noticed that at
the bottom there where it says grenade
hits restore melee energy yeah um you
know it's great out we're wondering
what's going on so that's an upgrade
that you've used it enough so now you
can use that yeah to reduce your melee
cooldown which the melee cooldown is not
that long
right i mean
the melee attack like it's a good second
punch
pretty
yeah quickly but
i guess if you can go faster
that guy had a shield so
all right so now i got my upgraded
enigma burn
pro tip yeah for you when you're looking
at items in your inventory yeah if you
want to compare two things hold the r2
button oh really yeah and that'll give
you a little side by side comparison
that's handy sean thank you
so i've already got let's see
these are the same 23 no special
abilities on that one
oh okay yeah you got to kick up your
boot game yeah my boot game is ready to
go
19 defense that looks like the
no-brainer
so this one is going to boost my
discipline what does it say oh let's
read what it says again
when the hunter accuses you of
disrupting his line of fire answer thus
it was imperfect and i could not abide
it
oh very specific that's good that's good
it was good
bungie is has long been known for their
kind of ability to blend very serious
tones with just comedy comedy and it
kind of it kind of comes out of nowhere
sometimes and like like there is a good
example of it
i could not abide it
that's good
what is that what is you have a bracelet
oh yeah that is my bond my warlock bond
which is like the class specific
armor
power bracelet the power bracelet all
right looks like i got some new
equipment new gear
no that would that just took me back but
equipment is like your ghost so you can
maybe get like vehicle go yeah different
ghost shells
different sparrows different jump ships
i like this emblem
yeah so this actually changes what you
see on your little
character badge up in the corners
as though you guys couldn't obviously
tell what's changing on the screen right
now
um i've got some tips on weapons
this is definitely going to be an
upgrade over my current auto rifle
mashallah
oh marshalla
see you later i'm going to go with the
hey girl well i'm upgrading from the
marshalla to the marshall
yeah but the range is less
is it
but the attack the attack is higher and
the magnet attack is like base damage
better magazine size
all right so
a fire fusion rifle neat
you know what let's try that i've been
relying on the shotgun quite a bit
lately i'm gonna go with the uh fire
fusion rifle yes please don't mind if i
do oh yeah
the interface in destiny
does take a little bit of getting used
to with the little uh cursor here it's
not like a standard console game where
you're just kind of like hitting down on
the d-pad and
jumping between auto selections i think
they have to give you that ability just
because you have to equip things yeah
and there's between the various so much
to look at all right
that's the mmo aspect creeping in
all right mary and i have just finished
the first mission separately
and
so soon we're going to be able to fire
team up and
adventure ooh i just didn't fire fire at
the level five kept hitting an active
firewall
oh so my mission is about
about to end so i can meet up with you
guys too
come on come on
bunches
jerks oh i was going to say something
why do you want to hang out with us
level twos face the darkness john i'm
going to invite you to my fire team and
he's protected actually maybe you should
be the fire team yeah i'll be a fire
team guy you guys want to go to like a
really high level fire squad obviously
all right
and oh i got a couple upgrades to choose
from
lucky
i'm gonna invite you to these nuts
all right
so this is a look at big hank
hanging out here he looks good with his
dead eye oh my god look at his dead eyes
look at your awful thing he's a
classically handsome human man but uh
was was marred in the dead eye attack
does make him prone to cheeky maneuvers
anything such as requiring depth
perception taking a book nap okay
you actually sat right on them how are
you doing
what's up
she she's i'm sitting on both her book
stacks whoa
how are you sitting on these books you
got one cheek hanging off before those
books i do
there's no way that's the kind of
physical discipline that a titan
class soldier chris reads through his
butt yeah that's his special i absorb
special attack book butt reading gonna
upgrade put on my free chest armor
uh so i got the kostov is like a heavy
i feel like it felt like a heavy rifle
but maybe it's just a little cumbersome
anyways i'm gonna go do the uh quick
little things that you have to do here
before we can hook up gunsmith
like crucible guy there's no reason to
talk to this dude right now so yeah
that the crucible is the competitive
multiplayer yeah mode
uh that's a it's like you get you access
it from the hub world like you do
uh like you access missions you just
choose to fly to the crucible instead of
to earth
and oh look at this nice tree
yeah that's a big old tree
how did they get this thing up here so i
have it looks like i finally unlocked
the crucible in mine so
and i just upgraded to level five so
that may be the threshold that you
needed five yeah all right i'm gonna
choose my weapon uh what have we have we
not seen something that hand cannon
i want something with big impact the
hand cannon has pretty here's me
i kind of want the hand cannon
i unlocked a new melee ability that that
face armor i chose wow looks like
eyebrows
robo eyebrows
i wasn't aware nice work row brows how
eyebrows my eyebrows would be oh that
guy's ingesting me
my dance is so robo
you guys watching my robo dance yes they
are
that is a pretty sweet robot down with
your bad self
my robo
i'm gonna equip i'm gonna get the pistol
because that seems you know not
prudent
this is exciting
i am gonna i'm able to play
guardian
should i go with a hand cannon as my
primary weapon that's what i'm doing
yeah
yeah uh sean i'm gonna finish
mary and i are just finishing up
grabbing these last
quick things and then once we do that
why don't you invite us to a fire team i
think it might have to load us into your
instance yeah uh but then we can all
roll
and you guys can see my hand cannon
who doesn't want to see that show you
big hank's hand cannon he's calling me
thank the traveler i only got a year
left
yes get your free robot
i got a robo shirt yeah
anything you get is robo
yeah
because you're a robo yeah i feel like
you guys are using that as a derogatory
term and i don't like it
what are they actually called exos xo is
the name of that race the robot race
robo roche
robo roche probatio
all these robots require a much bigger
level than i am can't get anything all
right get the free stuff
as always
all right i'm going to equip my new
armor
all right sean why don't you invite me
to your fire team when you get a dance
all right
cause i think i've just because i've
just completed all the basic stuff
let's see i will invite river dogs 14.
come on into my fire team
there's room for everybody
and then except for after you get to
three people should i invite you should
i just kill my room
welcome back jeff gerstmann to my fire
team
what if he rejects you
live on air
that's always the risk you run when you
invite people to your fire teams
choose a weapon guardian so
you sent me an invite but i can actually
you can also just join my fire team
from this screen here not enough space
on fire team it says so
i'm gonna go to the invitation
so i'm currently my fire team is set to
friends only
so by default it seems like you should
just be able to join it without me
having to send you an invite
uh so it says your fire team is holding
that's weird so that is a pro that's an
issue maybe uh do you maybe i can join
yours
sure give it a shot
unable to join the target player please
try
again all right mary keep going
finish your basic stuff all right i was
excited
no time for reading
people keep saying that to me
all right i'm it's not it hasn't given
me an instant you can't join this dude
message for the joining fire team
it's saying please wait while you're
connected with your fire team so
oh maybe it's loading up now i'm joining
sean's fire team you are yeah after you
do the ship right
shot as well
i'm 20 meters away
from
just hanging out with a janitor that
robot
your postmaster you got any mail for me
oh
no mail
so we're streaming the destiny beta
right now on playstation 4 we're also
giving away codes to the destiny beta
get in the gamespot comments leave a
comment on why you want a code and then
you'll be entered to win one of the
codes that will give you access to it on
ps3 or ps4 or xbox 360 or xbox one that
is to be determined once you enter it
into bungie.net it will produce three of
the codes on your chosen platform and i
imagine it's like just a playstation
code and it depends on which one you get
into i don't know
uh
sean so go ahead and do that to win a
code i just want to point out something
that i totally missed earlier what like
when i met up with the dude and we were
doing the mission and we started dancing
together and i was like can i join a
fire team with this guy uh-huh you can
so you you walk up to somebody that you
meet sure like this dude here oh you're
already like you're you're i don't want
you in my team uh like i walk up to this
guy and you get that little r3 prompt
you click r3
click options and then you can just
invite this rando into your fire team r3
students clicking on them don't do that
though because i want to be in your
fight all right so go to the menu press
option okay
shawn and i are having a dance party
this is we need a better place for a
dance party
it's too shady shouldn't dance to the
roster
and then
join fire team so there's not enough
space on fire team which is
weird can you join me i'm not friends
with you thai guy
how were you able to join mine after it
did that just move around a little bit
more and try it again yeah that's
literally what i did
electrolyte
okay
i like those odds
enough space on fire team
that's hard
you guys make some space
uh by mixing should we just invite
how about we just invite this rando to
our team
instead of mary
oh that guy left
i can inspect this player oh and i can
look at all their sweet gear chris do
you think i can give you gear
their fire team is now full
gave me the option to join it
and then it told me that i couldn't
join where are you chris
where did you go
i'm just standing there so if you guys
are just tuning in we're trying to get
uh a full three-person fire team
together but we're just having a little
bit of difficulty getting our third
person
to join which is mary
mary is kind of left in the lurch a
little bit here they keep saying that
it's not enough can i see there's not
enough space on your team except for
pretty close except the front request
that i just sent you ooh yeah
meanwhile
naps
well i could promote you to leader of
the fire team but that's not gonna
happen come on man i'd be great i'm
gonna inspect you
see so friends i go to chris and i can
see what kind of baby ammo he's got and
i can compare it to mine if i hold r2
so
helmet's like a lot better than yours
all right gauntlets are a pretty good
amount better than yours chest armor is
the same that's reflects poorly
enigma burn definitely better
all right i will try again
you can do it
try to join
run around a little bit more
i'll send you an invite how come you
guys are so busy
because there's so many people on your
sweet teams uh so i just
sent you an invite that wasn't able to
so you have to go to the messages on the
dashboard all right here we go
let's go to the left and choose join
hopefully this
so
early in the beta a little bit buggy uh
we're not able to get mary into this
fire team currently once you come back
outside why are you inside i mean come
on outside is the place to join people
on their fire teams obviously is it
maybe it's like the server that we're on
so try now see because you're outside
it's gonna work totally gonna work
totally
yeah
yeah obviously like i said
uh well sean let's go somewhere
and then you can join you can still try
to join our fire team when we go
somewhere so let's try going out of this
place you want to go to the moon chris
can we go to the moon i'd like to go to
the moon
let's have a conversation about the moon
i don't have a ship that can go to the
moon that's fine because i do
and i'm a boss you are i'm literally the
boss of this fire team yeah that's true
so you can have six people in a fire
team how about i invite you guys to my
fire team not interested
guys everything about that
not gonna happen session ended all right
so i've unlocked the crucible
so we could go do the crucible or
we could go to the gd moon oh
but this one
all right it's working i think mary's
joining her parking thai guy has joined
us
so this is known as me i don't have a
moon no it says requirements not met yet
i feel like i need to do the other story
missions yeah yeah okay you guys want to
do a level six story mission let's just
do something i want to show you level
five
i'm willing to die for my fire team and
connect it to long lines hey we're all
the fire team together you know what
this will be an experiment we're filling
our destiny we'll see what happens if we
have a couple like one high-level player
and a couple low-level players we'll see
if the mission balances out in any way
or let's see if you guys just get
totally blasted
don't worry i have
a sweet hand cannon
me too i'm going hand cannon is my
primary weapon and my backup weapon is a
fusion rifle fire fusion rifle fire oh
no i actually switched it
to a uh pulse rifle look our three ships
are diving towards earth that's adorable
oh look
they were running all that [ __ ] orbit
codes
we're hearing we are hearing dinkle
stereo yeah
we're hearing peter dinklage in
triplicate right now in the studio
i wish you guys could hear this effect
on the live stream it's fantastic it's
like listening to him in 3d yeah
three dinkles three dinkle 3d actually
stands for three
three dinklages
dink lie as
properly called incline
the plural the triple din collage triple
dink
here comes the triple dink
what is that our fire team name yeah the
triple tank triple dink is that not what
our fire team is called
dink drip dank drip dink yeah yeah why
not let's go with yes
well
it's been chosen by you the viewers
time to get all this loading time
actually happening
which ocean do you think we're flying
over
the pacific ocean
with atlantic
i'm gonna go with the english channel
yeah
sure i'm going with the antarctic sea
one of the great lakes i'm gonna go with
the wet lc oh what elsie yeah
probably doesn't exist anymore
in this future oh in this future world
that we live in i'm gonna go with
ontario
ontario
well choice odyssey
like the entire province of ontario one
of the five great lakes so
we came in and our
we came in to the thing and the three
animations were not happening at the
same time
but not but when we dove towards earth
they all happen hey guys what's up hey
hey
look at us
oh party time oh yeah oh yeah oh here we
go i'm tuckered out i like how i'm a
robot and my dance is so robot hey i
noticed that you guys don't have dope
yellow boots and gloves on you know it's
a good thing for us to do unfortunately
the very first time we get into a stream
together into an instance is just all
sit down for like five minutes
all right let's do this
i don't have any abilities and i have a
tiny gun hey you guys all have sparrows
right
no i said dicks oh
hand cannon
well
blasters
hand cannon is so good
what camera which which one of us is
sean
oh hand cannon
hand cannon is a little bit more of a
high skill level weapon than the
assault rifle
oh seven huh i think you're tough
tough dug
bam boom teach him how to duck
that guy had a doggie what the hell the
guy was invisible i can't oh yeah i have
uh unlocked the invisible enemies hey
come here come here
punch your jack i'm just gonna slap you
in the mouth
you guys see my punch i'm gonna sever
your jugular it's just a straight up
punch
come on that's it that's it it's only a
punch all right let's go what are we
doing we're going towards the carrot
yeah we're going towards punch each
other a little bit more
how about we uh proceed with the mission
for the sake of our lovely viewing
audience you guys have been sticking
with us and now we are finally
fulfilling our
destiny oh yeah destiny's a better word
to uh roll together you almost had me oh
get dugged
oh
not fast enough
seems like you guys are doing okay
against these level five
vinnies obviously are they level five
yeah
oh look we got some more duders coming
over here should we invite them to our
fire team xavier no we're full
you're trying to get me out sean i'm
sick of it i'm actually going to have
six people in your fire i'm just saying
we got some dead weight here
you're getting better we could have a
big dance party if we just
waited for those dudes no we're just
going to keep going
listen some of us haven't been shooting
dudes for the past hour and we're eager
to shoot some dudes also i thought we
were proceeding with the mission sean
seriously i'm going to climb up this
ravine
shawn can't go up cause he's in a boat
and i can barely go okay i'm on
what's up dudes
okay you went up it that was but that
was boss that was pretty boss right i'm
not gonna lie to you that was probably
the most boss thing i've ever done in my
life
i'll go back over to where my
show your face
i punched that dude to death
well
i punched him to death you came in and
you just
finished him off a little bit now now i
mean
to death is the killing blow a death
punch is a death punch and he definitely
went in the direction of my mega punch
that's fair that's fair not split hairs
to go with my uh secondary weapon
so the pulse rifles in this game uh our
weapons you actually have to charge down
for like two seconds before you can fire
them i believe the common nomenclature
is charged charge up charge up not
charge down
you have to charge them up surface now
keeping the fallen busy
this are we doing the same thing we've
done like three times now on this stream
go through this area have you gone
you've gone i've gone through this area
an amount of time so far
but you couldn't find the stairs last
time so
this is where the uh the angry dudes
came charging at me last time
further
because the wizard from the moon is not
here
maybe
that wizard came from the moon
dude get your head out of my gun
are you talking to me
listen
if i'm in front of you i have the right
of way
that gun etiquette is famous driving
oh guys i'm super charged i don't want
to brag but i am super charged mary is
super dead i died oh did you die mary
don't worry i revived you all right
because teamwork
come here get punched
yeah
oh i got punched so hard you gotta you
gotta do me a solid mary okay i'm
i'm coming waters or sean all right i
got this i got you guys oh look at you
it's your little spirit hole
you survived my spirit hole wait why did
you go all the way back there when i rev
did i not finish did not properly revive
you
you gotta hold down the button that's
what i did
i thought i did it maybe you didn't i
may be jordan because poor thai guy is
left i did have to run back yeah maybe i
blew it sorry
here i was thinking i was a hero
when in reality you are a not hero yeah
like or maybe some word that rhymes with
hero
zero
nero i mean zero seems like a little bit
nero like a bad roman emperor
yeah i wasn't i was more of a nero yeah
yeah like a
like a guy who caused a lot of harm to
roam i think we're just gonna have to
play a little cautiously edith
oh you did so hard you just i love my i
love my super yeah what can i say
are these mines what are these things
did you poop
is this your spore
hey chris uh keep up with the pace all
right listen i'm just trying to look at
poop balls
i've advanced they're called i'm not
gonna say it they're called
dingleberries
ah nailed it he said he wasn't gonna say
it but then i did i immediately changed
my mind i immediately changed my mind it
was good
okay guys sorry i was exploring
elsewhere uh-oh i'm gonna catch up
there so fast you guys gonna be so proud
of me
do you guys suppose that they're is an
ability to mark no i did
places on the screen
to like drive around and revive
the court the ghosts are still here
they're falling i don't know
to set a waypoint yeah like drop a white
point there's another one i feel like
there probably is
oh i can summon a vehicle
oh hey
runs a little basically guys
way station
oh we got some buddies going on over
here actually no these are two enemy
factions fighting each other
oh i did a real bad attack oh looks like
somebody has to get revived because he
sucks at video games in
life i know that song oh my god
i need to revive maybe dragon the level
twosies on no i just need to say fiverr
was a bad idea
maybe you guys should stop playing like
a couple of wild cards yeah that is
definitely we are
he's been trying to punch a lot of
people
that time i was trying to do vehicular
homicide okay so i am uh using the hand
cannon which is the totally dope
revolver primary weapon
which uh definitely packs a punch
although as you'll notice much slower
rate of fire all blasted still holds
that i picked up a dead ghost let's find
the array
dead ding
important
oh that guy's hiding back there boom
nope
bandage
don't worry i got vengeance for you
thank you
i just softened them up a little bit all
right we got some thralls over here
actually we don't need to go that way we
need to go to the where there's some
other bad guys over here
let's just agree that they're bad guys
there's pretty much a lot of bad guys
yeah we're in a bad guy heavy zone
that's what's happening
take cover
oh no yeah nice head shot whoever was
covering me there thank you
i wonder if you guys are collecting xp
faster now that you're dealing with
higher level
dudes i would imagine you probably how
far are you oh we're about both um
chris and i are both about
to level up i feel like you probably are
collecting xp faster
all right we are headed this way
follow the team leader
yes team leader
later i didn't vote for him the darkness
is growing stronger we have to finish
this you guys know the darkest growing
oh stronger want some yellow boots
all right we're entering the darkness
though oh yeah did you see what don't do
you when you don't die right yeah okay
don't die did you see what happened to
you when you did that
the screen effect yeah yeah no but like
your physical body oh no
decorporealized and then re-corporately
re-corporealized pretty big word i'm a
pretty big dude well let's see if that
keeps you alive
ty
we're live streaming live streaming okay
internet
yeah
but the stream got delayed an hour boom
can you get someone to fill in for me
all right here we go shooting dragon if
you guys want to discuss
oh punches
punches no i didn't do it punches and
bunches
sean what
i didn't die that i didn't die yet you
didn't you didn't die yet mary you did
you die no i did not die all right we're
doing good keep it up for our team
fire team away
wow
oh doug there's some dugs watch out for
those dogs chris
stick your face out and shoot it oh you
just space punched that yeah i did that
was tight
oh so close to level up
leveling
i want my ability i want to do a titan
attack or whatever the thing is called
this is it
hey eric do you want to take my spot
i will be back mary's got to run to a
meeting i will be back we have eric tay
jumping peek-a-boo
oh god oh gosh
oh i'm gonna die
oh don't die
oh i'll save you all right i'll be back
oh
sweet thai guy wait
i did the revive but then you didn't
come back oh you're back
just move slightly tay
move
look at your look at your screen look at
you
grab your control lightly move to the
left grab the controller move to the
left yeah that's exactly what i'm
talking about
that's that kind of listening to me when
i panic yell at you that's gonna really
i'm gonna fire a nova blaster this
captain
what up el capitan where is
oh that's cause he's dead chris cause i
just killed him like a boss i see him i
see his dead captain corpse with no head
on it
ah there's a bunch of those little
flying guys
they're called birds
i believe they're called thanks oh okay
sorry i thought you were talking about
different things like in real life yeah
what's in that level up though
did you just level up
nice eric tay welcome to the stream eric
tay everybody filling in for mary
thanks for helping us with the things
a couple uh couple instructions for you
eric what's that die
uh don't die don't die because we're in
a no respawning zone okay trick is to
don't die uh aside from that did you
play the alpha nope all right eric eric
tay's very first time playing destiny
this will be fun it's pretty standard uh
first person shooter control type stuff
you got your grenade on l1 i believe
which is on a cooldown
uh the only big difference is that melee
is on oh there's the invisible dudes
oh where are they uh they're murdering
me oh i punched one but then
i got you buddy
you're not dying on my watch little
buddy thank you so i think we're outside
that darkness zone because you're
totally just respawning right here yeah
well no because you revived me
you're still in the darkness right as
you can see from the health bar at the
top
okay
uh we're definitely still in the
darkness zone sean did you you like that
that little uh okay i just leveled up
for you killing something sweet
um xp radius did
sean's got to lead this this squad oh
yeah i'm the squad leader okay so i need
to find some eric go to options and
unlock your ability that you just got so
go to the
thing with the plus press triangle and
choose upgrade because now we can do
like the rocket pack
jump yeah oh so it's different by class
so
press
x
no the double jump so like oh
well mine is like a lift
like
because mine is like a total like jet
pack situation
mine's kind of like a jet pack
different
this is like a double jump mine has like
you can hold your burn yeah
yeah you can hold your suit what the
they get the shot i think it goes higher
sorry eric let's have a jumping contest
shawn ready three two wait hold on let's
stand next to each other oh wait i'm
looking for all right you're gonna be
you're gonna be the judge eric ready
wait one two three go
looking like shawn and he's got more
hang time he does have more hands he's
got way more hang time i don't i mean i
don't know how to tell you this but i'm
a total total
boss right so there's just a lift thing
that i can trigger once and i have no
control over i've got to warn you guys
there's a captain oh you see this guy
are we doing this guy yeah captain ron
oh he's dead now wow 637 grab that ammo
granata there's the controls so ammo
depending the ammo drops are differently
colored white is primary ammo
uh
green is secondary and pink yes heavy
weapon i think yeah
it's working english outside the array
it's opening it's opening dinkle's doing
the dink all right get dinked
so hard
it's activated
all right guys i want to see something
amazing we're going to have some enemies
happen
cutting through
no that doesn't sound cool can we get
back inside it sounds hella bad yeah
probably
i need more ammo i'm kind of boned here
guys what where is shawn i'm still in
here you should reload i'm looking for
ammo
watch out for those attack balls coming
in yeah watch out for the attack balls
oh crap
i need to go inside yeah gotta grab that
ambo niches watch out don't get shot
some sort of wizard from the moon
uh well so this we have to defend this
area okay hence this shield icon i
gather
thanks chris
oh grab that ammo oh spaceballs
i'm pretty set on ammo are you yeah my
second oh look at this big dude
oh that's a
nice
it's like a okay could could a dude
revive me yeah you got him i got him
oh i got an encrypted engram
i might have just blown my subaru just
man it might have been a bad time to use
it although it'll recharge with more
enemies do you see these glowing balls
what are they
somebody tell me i think those are when
uh
i don't know mama thrall loves a daddy
for all i want a baby for all of us and
mama for all
sorry yeah
pistol are you still using the magnum
oh he's got a shield too that's not fair
life's not fair eric
life's not fair
what is that purple thing is that your
pulse rifle yeah it's got like a
lightning
and it's got an elemental attack to it
oh the hollowed knight just holed up in
some kind of fire shield yeah oh god
if you hollow knight
you get grenaded
got a shield
that dude dead
definitely not dead
like a bus
oh that ammo i get that ammo yeah make
sure you get ammo nice work triumphing
music up in here yeah
oh so there's not like chest or anything
what the hell is a war mind
but it's connecting to defense
constructs all across the system
there could be something out there
yeah
all right uh there are like loot chests
they tend to be hidden around the level
though
i didn't find any um
i didn't find no loot man you do eric
you do get like post mission rewards uh
like quests or whatever yeah okay so
you'll see it like in a second oh so
close to fist of havoc
did you go tank
yeah a new helmet which is not as good
as my current one
unfortunately 33 kills ancient recording
recording captured by your ghost of the
rasputin firewall of interest to the
tower gunsmith
let's continue along shall we
we just hit x or whatever to get out uh
no he just he's the fire team leader so
he
takes charge
and goes onward
all right uh i got a i got a duke
mark 10.
i got a big hand cannon
rude
rude dude
uh
hey folks chris waters here with sean
mcinnis and eric tay we're streaming the
destiny beta giving away destiny codes
to you guys if you want to go over to
gamespot comments leave a comment saying
why you want to get in on this beta
action and be entered to win a code
that'll be redeemable for ps3 ps4 xbox
360 or xbox one depending on what you
choose on bungie.net when you enter it
and it'll spawn three codes
once you enter it and you'll get three
codes on whatever platform you choose so
you can give them to your little
friendos and have a fire team like we
got going on right here
yeah yeah yeah yeah
fire team
it's cool you guys got some cool planes
kind of looks like mine you like these
you like this this ride
i feel like it's analogous to like a
a star wars like an eight wing or
something i don't know my star wars
wings too too well sure yeah you want to
keep going
so why don't you guys goof around in the
tower for a minute all right we're gonna
do it right we're gonna do a quick uh
tower goofing we're gonna speak to the
gunsmith give people a little tour of
the tower okay here we have the dance
arena which is where everybody comes out
early eric tay i want to see some dance
moves here
press yep not up
it's not all not down nope it's not
left it's right it's right oh yeah so i
got a question for you yeah when we're
in combat how come we don't look
anything like this
because we're wearing all of our gear
the helmet
the the chest guard the all that stuff
if you look at sean's character who is
right all the way over here
you can see like the new yellow oh yeah
yeah yellow the new gauntlets the new
greaves the new the new boots whatever
um
are you interacting with the locals
that's their people are really happy but
the helmet obscures your head
so when you're in combat you don't see
the head that you customized okay
well i was in like full black too
yeah okay oh it's just well so you're
also not really yeah you're not really
seeing yourself
okay unless you are next to someone
who's playing with you and looking at
their tv because it's in first person
during that yeah although some abilities
i think take you into third person why
am i going down here at the gunsmith oh
no i'm following you
you're my tour guide so actually going
down there yeah we'll do that in a
minute all right but going to the
gunsmith to collect our mission reward
let's see what that is all about there's
the sick tree which everyone must admire
yep the tree of life
some god rays coming through
beautiful beautiful
gunsmith
okay let's go
oh a green which she did at the array
could change our future
i got machine gun and rocket launcher so
these are uh special
weapons i believe
it's a third weapon class but i'm not
sure what do you got i have the same
thing you do you have machine gun and
rocket launcher i think it's machine gun
machine gun rocket launcher yeah i was
looking at yours they look the same what
are you what are you going to take i
think you should compliment yeah
what do you want
what do you want to do you want to rock
it or you want a machine gun i don't
know i'm kind of feeling like uh if i'm
the the heavy dude i should rock a
machine gun okay i can i can specialize
the rocket yeah see what's the
difference
oh yeah don't forget to look at the
second area that you're gonna
potentially level up oh right kills for
this weapon grant bonus damage for a
short time weapon grows more accurate
the longer it's fired i don't like that
styles
a lot like the long fire i like this one
has the half the magazine
but it has
a
bigger impact slower rate of fire
i think i'm gonna go choose this one
what do you what are your rocket
launcher choices uh so one looks like it
has a
very slightly slower rate of fire but it
has a bigger blast radius
but it has less velocity
but i'm looking at the secondary
and it seems like this one would
probably be better because it increases
the reload speed when it's empty and it
only has a magazine of one
yeah so you're gonna want to be able to
like sure
rocket that so we'll take that guy
you should do the trick eat
all this stuff
is this stuff you can buy from him or is
it just yes okay when you're at the
appropriate level
don't leave it so long next time
okay i'm back
oh it's a heavy weapon so that's what we
just got or heavy
yeah gotcha
sean we're going to get a heavy weapon
oh really yes rocket and i'm going to
take a quick break oh all right it's
time for chris to take his break time to
fall ashore all right
let's see i'm going to decrypt
i picked the first machine
and mary hasn't gotten very much gear
well she just started
so
all right point counterpoint
out rifle
oh did you get some greens yeah but it's
a scout rifle which is not really the
weapon you trade me i'm focusing on is
there trading in this game there might
be i haven't figured out how to do it
yet
head to this gunsmith do it get your
heavy
machine gun
rocket launcher
yeah so there's two rocket launchers and
two machine guns i took a rocket
launcher and then i got two machine guns
and one rocket launcher right now
there's two yeah yeah
it looks like the it's the same
the cost reward
cyrus and oryx
oh
nice we all picked different ones
all right so if you guys are just tuning
in once again we are live streaming the
destiny beta been going for a couple
hours now
currently we're in the tower which is
the
um between mission hub area where you
can go and
get new items and buy new stuff and uh
take on new missions and whatnot um
let's see okay
they'll have to wait
all right so you guys all
kitted out
i mean we got what we could i think
yes titan survey data what's up dinkles
it's your buddy peter dinklage
all right
yeah i like your blue one better yeah i
did like the look of it better
i think
you're starting to match your yellow
yeah
sorry i'm really about aesthetics yeah i
can tell that you get very obsessive
compulsive when it comes to your rpg
loot
what's up dinkles i'm back
do you buy have you bought helmets or
anything
just kind of go with what you can uh i
haven't bought any stuff yet it seems
like you get a pretty
generous stream of
loot
early on so i haven't
felt the need to buy anything yet what's
like your actual currency the currency
is glimmer okay so how do you tell how
much glimmer you're right it's
the one below your rank it's actually
not that oh that's not that is um
it's like codex stuff or something uh
there's some word
you can just mouse over or just go in
the right one no
uh this is your glimmer it's in your
inventory the blue grimoire score oh man
look at that the grimoire score is the
number underneath your level number in
your on your player card oh there's it
your glimmer is the currency of the city
gotcha yeah
and then cause you can also there's a
currency
for crucible stuff as well
and oh what
fix that
all right so in in the inventory
i think you i got this black wax idol
that is a consumable a misshapen figure
that transmutes into glimmer as you
strike down hive enemies last a short
time definitely not made of wax
so like
if i'm fighting hive i can use this
consumable and then it will
glimmer will come out of it
what do you have
all right well let's see what i have i
have
a silken codex a tome of cramped glyphs
bound in a silk of unknown origin always
of interest to the cryptarch in the
tower you should give it see what
happens when you take it to the crypt
arc what are we doing
i got something for you
hey guys hey mary mary's back from a
meeting i'm back mayor's back we're
going to comic-con
yeah we are
all right so i basically i just took it
to the crypt arc and sold it for 200.
got some months yeah not sure what eric
did you know 400 blooms uh basically we
got heavy weapons oh you've got a rocket
launcher i think you can check your
inventory and spot it did i
get my ult
your
you did get the double jump though what
level do you get that i want to say
level four four i believe a double jump
well you can't use it not here here oh i
see all right let's go to another uh
mission
well this is all higher level stuff than
i can buy yeah
let's go all right let's do a mish
a little mishmash
go to orbit and dance my way into orbit
package
i didn't hold the button down long
enough
you have to really impatient you have to
really want to go to orbit like they
don't want you to accidentally go to
orbit like oops i'm in orbit because i
mean at least in the beta here there are
some pretty substantial load times
uh you know
is it optimizing
loading in the the choice menu like now
sean is going to be able to set the
destination
um
let me see if we can go to the moon yet
can we go oh the moon mission is still
lost on lockdown
i can go to earth
yeah so basically i have the level two
story mission
as what i can choose but you can choose
whatever and we can just go there right
so whatever you want to do is cool
with me
i don't know mayor you have any
uh level six strike
we haven't what level are you now
uh i'm level five i think i'm level
three i feel like a level six strike is
going to be a bad idea that seems
ambitious it does oh this is the this
was in the alpha the one against sepik's
prime which is the big floaty orb that
you never got to the end of the alpha no
all right well it went on vacation that
one is definitely tough
uh so we've done this one we've done
this one
we've done this one
we've done this one you can do a free
roam thing yeah do you guys want to do a
free room one let's do that at least
until we get let's do like one of those
missions okay and try to go in a
direction that's not the same direction
we went before like maybe i don't know
do you have any requests from the chat
of what to do again folks for checking
out the chat at twitch.tv gamespot as
well as the comments on gamespot.com if
you have any questions or
uh requests because on the moon here
it says i just want to get to the
requirements not met
so i feel like
since it's a story mission you have to
you have to get to that level whereas
other
missions you can do even if you're lower
in level
um
that's my guess at least so what does it
say when you go to the
oh oh
maybe that just means that it's not in
the beta can't go to the moon in the
beta
destiny launch coming soon activity
unavailable
all right well like
okay so is that what happened when you
clicked on it yeah
yeah see on my screen if i click on
something that says requirements not met
it doesn't tell me anything okay
well let's uh why don't we do oh no
that's not what it meant to do earth
i'd also do the crucible
that's true well we should at least
get our special powers before going to
the crucible fair enough all right
we'll do the free roaming things yeah
free ride and some money free fram
anybody who's familiar with test drive
unlimited knows the value of free ride
instant money boom fram
so
would you say so far i mean we've been
playing for a couple hours it doesn't
look like you can go to the moon
you gave you gave you that message that
indicates that it's not in the beta
that's what it looks like do you think
that
so what if what about the possibility
that all the story missions you and we a
little bit have completed
what about the possibility that that's
all the story missions in the beta
what if that were the case that might be
oh wait somebody died already does that
seem less than does that seem less than
alpha like less than there was in the
alpha or no there's definitely been more
missions so far
because there was the earlier missions
yeah outlets they skipped overnight
you know how you pull out your
tap the
touch pad
yeah but how do you pull out your heavy
weapon oh so you hold triangle for a
second
so instead of tapping triangle you hold
it and that's how you get to the heavy
weapon i don't have any ammo for but
yeah you don't start with ammo for the
heavy weapon you actually have to find
it
find it let's find a mission all right
there's one over here
let's head this way
gun looks eerily similar to my last area
is
that voice actor who gave that mission
was lieutenant daniels from the wire
i don't know his real name
my ride is all messed up you guys yeah i
parked it in this cave so it's cool
let's see if this rando wants to join
our fire
group
hey rando
illa killa yeah
you
join our fire team
see if he joins all right let's go randy
rando randy rando
i see some bad guys over here
they're level two vandals
the plow
oh bang ooh head shot i like that
oh yeah watch the soul escape your dead
alien body i want to watch the light
leave from your eyes
that's pretty grim and wow that's kind
of what i said very specific
punch
there was multiple melees at once
denied i just want to complete rando to
join our group is that too much to ask
for
eliminate a fallen vandal heading a crew
holed up inside the wall
close to levels don't worry guys i'm
just going to take out all these dudes
for funsies come on what we're
progressing
i'm killing doug's over here those dogs
have families
think of all the doug children who will
never see their dog father ever again
listen
it's hard out there for a dog
all right let's head up this way you
guys want to know a little shortcut but
there oh
that didn't work i was
i was pretty good
hey hey i don't know
wow i did it
you did it i did it i didn't do it i'm
i'm a cool dude
oh what loot chest oh what
where's this mythical loot chef oh you
guys are
grabbing invisible loot chests you
already grabbed that loose i already
grabbed it in your world you guys were
interacting with invisible so yeah mary
and i could see that loot chest but sean
has already looted it so it was not in
his world wasn't visible yeah
so we got the loot
that shawn already all right here comes
a group of bad dudes chucking a grenade
punch them yeah
you just clocked that dude uh you have
the best melee it's so good i had a
front row seat to that one you really do
have just the best melee attack so
that's the best part
it's delightful
so we're gonna try to kill a vandal now
that this thing that i have in my
inventory says like
consume it
uh transmutes into glimmer as you strike
down hive enemies
so fallen are not hive right like
correct the fallen are dugs and vinnies
the hive is the the alvin's and the the
the thrall dudes right i think so
like i think yeah i want to say that's
what i mean
so far i haven't seen one of those
public events i just got rifle shot
yeah
boom
this thing can can hit it distance
my little uh magnum
get dinked
that's what peter dinklage says to
anybody he meets for the first time you
mean in team dink
i found a reaver oh god
i feel like i'm not where you guys are
i'm the one now getting ready oh [ __ ] i
might get wrecked by this vandal oh i
got wrecked
but i killed him can you guys uh maybe
do a little revival i got you
oh god
don't worry
everything is so much stronger than me
it takes like eight shots
yeah we're definitely hitting like level
six enemies just a little perseverance
is all that's necessary
oh look this this is a player character
who is level exclamation point oh no
he's four
that's weird where is he
he's over here fighting with this
reapered leaper should i invite him to
our uh group
or
i don't i don't want to invite him if
you think he's like a shitty dude he
seems fine she he who knows
shad i trust him
trust him because there's literally
nothing get in my fire team bro to voice
foil you
did you do a preliminary dance to your
invitation no i just i just straight
invite people i feel like you shouldn't
do that before damn you think i should
dance first yes i think you should wave
first dance is when they get in you
can't just dance
anyone really there's there are enemies
afoot
hey dude dude
don't worry guys i'm shooting dudes
yeah i mean a little bit
from time to time hello sean hello
oh i found some spin metal leaves why is
this dude not joining our dude party
he seems like kind of
guys you're losing track of the task at
hand which is to
be moving this way what do you mean i'm
over here shooting dudes
i shot a dude
should take cover on me vandal
blast it
super there is a good amount of cover
around oh yeah
there are many sean you generated one
orb of light what are these orbs of
light like i think that you can you look
around and see because i think that
oh i found a loot chest guys
come to your buddy sean where where
where's sean find your buddy sean
right over here the green dots do not oh
what explain yeah
no
green dots show that they're on the same
altitude as you there's some did you see
the spin metal leaves along or also
around here
mary did you find this thing no go to go
to where we are go to the place go into
the place
hello
over here back here go to where i'm
shooting
go to where chris is i'm watching the
shooting river dogs i go where the
bullets are not where the guards are go
down there just look around
whoa it's all gone there's nothing there
huge mother effort i didn't know that
that was gonna be the case i just
thought it was funny when it was all
right jerks
come over here we're the dancing alien
lady is
which is me oh man i'm totally just
carrying a bazooka on my back that's
yeah you got a real
noob tube back there
whoa bazooka is not a noob tube no ma'am
noob tube isn't under
launcher
really yeah
fair enough
all right i'm gonna use my heavy weapon
next time we get into some heavy combo
all right this is the mission type place
where the mission is oh really yeah
so you're saying i should use my heavy
weapon
oh yeah i'm gonna i should too
oh i'm out of heavy weapon ammos
f a v
this thing's tight
did we do the mission tight yeah i
freaking murked that dude hey you did
that
you gave that good a
bad name yeah you gave that guy a good
marking
uh look around for chess maybe i don't
know is it too late for chest looking
chest search
search
bin metal
things i think we just got to go back no
we don't have to frantically run around
because we're not going to get
automatically teleported back we just
have to look for missions that are
available because this is the free
running mission
so we got to go back out into the open
and find those little green beacons on
there once we came
yeah so there's more out here
i'm just going to be i'm going to go
yeah you do what you gotta do i'm gonna
go trigger it don't worry
you'll find it i have faith in you thank
you well i do too i have a
big sense of faith i feel like i'm going
deeper into the wall
i think he's
gonna you're welcome
your eyes light up
no don't wait up it's fine i'm coming
i'll be fine
oh really guys i'll be fine
you got this guys i'm going to be fine
how about you hit the touch pad and it's
going to give you a little white icon
and that's where you go i know where to
go
don't act like i don't know
oh
decked yeah that dude did definitely did
that
he got dome decked he got decked in the
dome all right i see a mission
trigger point over here and i'm gonna go
trigger it
where are you mission here it is all
right guys
get ready hey guys what are you doing
over here
oh take out fallen drags and vandals and
gather the ether supps they depend on
for life
that was a terrible maneuver that was
terribly awesome oh my goodness
i'm in a tight
i just smashed my car into a bunch of
these dudes and
and how does it work out it's it's still
working itself out i'm
this just like a big old beat down with
me oh i died i died help me out i died i
beat him down don't worry
i got some ether sucks
all right tonight we shall sup on ether
there's some ether subs over here
did you get your subs mary
i think they're shared
i think that was fun what do i do we got
we still got 68 percent more what's up
58
more
i don't know
what is up
stop
uh it's this food it's their food
basically we're just stealing their
lunch yeah we're stealing their lunch so
that they each started we are basically
murdering them and stealing their lunch
money tactic
oh yeah this is this is some serious
potato famine technique oh
yeah but but true
harsh but true harsh but true okay
historically proven
oh there's a drop ship of bad dudes
coming in you should go to where that
boat is at
let's totes go to that best way to get
to a boat don't ride your ah you're so
bad at that it's so fun
what do you mean i'm so bad at it you
are really bad at it that's literally
what i mean is that you are yeah
you just brush that dude away it's all
you i know sometimes you can hit them
though and it's awesome
oh i got my leave a little
nose dude dead
are you dead dude hold on level up boom
oh
guess who just oh i didn't
give me them oh okay here we go public
events happening you guys want to do
this
we'll get hells of xp for it all right
we also got subs and i also unlocked my
ability mary quick press option
okay go go go
unlock your ability why am i getting
shot who's shooting
where is this happening
i want an r1 this could be bad all right
here comes the devil walker you guys
ready for this uh it's going to be dope
as hell yeah i'm ready for this
he danced on its corpse
once the battle has concluded oh shiz i
died immediately uh-oh
can you come help me please can you come
help me please i was upgrading i'm
revolving
i'm on the other side of the building i
got you homie i got you he's got you
thank you for getting me
i'm a little scared of him i'm not gonna
lie
it should be that thing is gnarly yeah
that thing is a boss
the thing is
but you know what i got go on
i little rocket launcher dealie so shoot
its legs by the way
attacking its weak spot not the headband
i got you covered oh i just got oh i got
marked i guess
can you revive a dude
i'm dead yeah mary come over there to
the right just down there to the right
there's a bad guy i'm good
i gotta protect my i mean i can press to
respawn is there any penalty for that uh
you're just slightly farther away
all right oh i'm gonna die
so i know how to cover distance fast oh
i don't get a regular bag i died again
let alone giant spider hang out with
mary all right you hang out with mary
you know what i'm going to i'm going to
charge in and marry that guy that's what
i'm going to win back with sean god damn
it shoot the legs shoot the legs shoot
the legs
don't shoot the red killed by the devil
watcher
i'm gonna throw a super edit protect me
protect me guys
we're dead i get god
how are you that close to him because
i'm a boss
all right
so it's not necessarily that there's a
penalty for dying it's that you have to
kill him within this amount of time
okay
and obviously the more you die the
slower you do
feel like oh
yeah shoot the legs shoot the legs hold
on
this drag is up in my
business business
shooting front right leg yeah busted one
yeah good job
taking it yeah oh it's immune oh i was
shooting the wrong part so should we
shoot the vulnerable part yeah
all right
oh [ __ ] oh yeah that's it's big heavy
attack you do not want to be around that
thing
that'll wreck you good
i'll do a wreck-it ralph on you
all right i shot front oh yeah all right
sound
oh crap
can i come in i'm coming in hot with the
romper stuff
boom
oh this thing's dead this thing's going
down i just hit it with my special shot
good work chris yeah i'm proud of you oh
it's immune
i want to use my special you can't hit
the legs when it's down yeah mary your
special is dope you basically just get
this sick glowing gun
and you get like two shots with it
should i i should use that when he's
prone it seems like a good call
so what's the weak spot you shoot when
it shoots the legs and then its head
will expose a weak spot oh it's the
glowing red part of this dome yeah
it's a glowing weak spot for massive
damage
oh
blasted
yeah
well i got a thousand damage
well i can't i'm definitely not going to
be able to ride you out there
i'll revive we're so close to killing it
guys we can do this
definitely can do this we can definitely
i have to have a punch fight with some
dregs i'm gonna just chuck a grenade at
it from downtown
i might have thrown my grenade too far
i died
oh did not like that
yes
boom bang
kapow kablam kebbler oh it's open
there's like a big open hole
oh nuts what's the uh cool down
for your special it's right above your
weapon
readout oh yeah there she is it's pretty
long
we're out of time
running out of time
we're so close to killing it though
we're down to a minuto here
oh it's got like a one little sliver of
life left
kill it kill it kill it kill it kill it
i'm gonna go punch it nope bad idea
these shanks are giving me oh you gotta
just focus on it focus on it there's
such a little yeah don't worry about the
drags
oh it blasted the crap out of me
go go shoot it shoot it
we can do this 20 seconds i'm running in
i'm doing this you're gonna die [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
[ __ ] you
yeah you're dead get dead get pruned get
dead get it oh
dead ah it's kind of dead looking is it
dying i mean i'm dead yeah
yeah
how much time did we have left like not
much yeah really small very little time
left they're still bad guys yeah don't
get cocky oh there was a big one all
right i saw that i saw you oh caught
your death we blasted that thing up that
was totally at the end there i was just
charging in and trying to melee its legs
that was so dumb
that was real dumb guys i'm not gonna
lie to you
good job team i wanna i wanna wave to
this guy
good work everybody
wave to shadow i'm gonna do a
celebratory is there a dodge
is there a dodge yeah let's do dance on
the dance on its grave situation
let's get in on this oh yeah here we go
how are we on time
guys in the back how are we on time is
this like is that a fitting end to our
destination i feel like that's a pretty
good end to the lives we did take down
that big boss thing that was pretty
tight yeah
yeah i'll go ahead and wrap it up here
oh yeah let's just uh
oh yeah we're gonna have a little
tuckered out
let's see
all right thanks for watching everyone
of course good luck to those who have
entered to win codes by commenting on
the video on gamespot still chance if
you go in there and tell us why you want
to get into the destiny beta or what
your favorite moment was from our live
stream put it in there you entered to
win a code and you can get in on it
yourself
uh what are we are we dancing yeah we're
dancing out let's dance this one out uh
for sean mcguinness mary kish eric tay
bonito on the back all the folks who
helped out i'm chris waters thank you
for watching see you next time